hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of riffin with Griffin as you
know this has been a fantastic ride I
really appreciate all the feedback all
the love people are giving me and you
know each week sometimes I say this is
another special episode but honestly
this is legitimately another special
episode another special guest one of my
best friends in the world
the talented been in a business 29 years
here the fabulous Dane Cook
all right there was a good rehearsal
let's bring the energy up a little bit
it's great to be here man I'm so glad
you've been texting back and forth I'm
gonna do it I've been hounding when I'm
ready when you fix your lighting in here
I said this light is not good for
ultra-white you know to me that's good
if we were making a Scorsese film in
here I don't know you're too busy to
listen to my podcast you know No yeah
everyone says the same thing I've heard
some clips just whatever I heard you
this is a Steven Wright episode and the
Bob gold wait yeah
but I'm always looking for a new theme
song and I had a good one last week in
week before but here's another great
theme song okay you don't judge this
theme song this is no no we're not Jake
enjoy it we're gonna enjoy it if you
have something to say you can say
something else we can we swear on this
and what you like oh yeah yeah yeah we
can we if you know if you don't like
this [ __ ] theme song it's fine but
this theme song is a sent in by Kody
cachet has sent this one in this is from
Kody everybody this
[Music]
agnese song already
[Music]
looks like ice ice baby yeah here's the
message that you won't forget I'm gonna
wake you up I just draw the beat now
it's time for you to get out
[Music]
all right we want thank Cody cachet for
sending in a another banger you know I'm
gonna compile all these songs together I
might come out with my own EP but
anyways the the fabulous Dane Cook is
here and thank you sir for coming in
once yeah man so I know let's get the
real the gist of business stuff out of
the way all right you got your 29th year
and you're going on tour again yeah a
big tour you're going on a huge 47 city
tour at least right now they're probably
adding cities as we're speaking 29 years
in the business
yeah and you're still going on a 47 city
tour yeah because and I think you
understand this more than anybody when
you feel like you're primed up and the
material is honed and probably over
cooked sometimes because we're going up
and I intended you need to get out there
you need to you need to bring it out and
you know what this this I've been
toiling around La for almost three years
since troublemaker so it's the most
amount of time I've worked material
before getting back out on the road and
doing an official tour last year was
like an unofficial underground like am i
funny here still tour and then once that
the feedback came I was like let's go
you know it's weird because it's like I
feel like people don't know you they
think they know this no I tell you man
they don't know anything about you
you're from Boston you know your career
how does all right let me let me do me
tell you why okay you came up at a time
that was like pre a lot of the stuff
that's happening right now okay you
actually on the forefront of like social
media right like you was used on MySpace
and said oh this what was your thought
that was like this is my forte I'm a
computer geek I love all that stuff and
I loved promotion I really loved meeting
fans and cultivating all the behind the
scenes from Flyers to posters to album
art so getting online and doing all that
stuff and HTML code was like right up my
alley so you know yeah I'd go home every
night after the club and I just
correspond with people all night you
know it's like I like video games with
people all night and then you would and
then but
like did you even know that you had the
idea that like myspace was gonna be as
large as it was and it turned into like
that was like the the grandfather of
what social media is right now yeah I
mean obviously it we wish it stuck
around for you know reasons that I did
count Facebook vine and all these kinds
of things Instagram
that's all stems from I said I said I
was there the day I was born
and because I held it when it died but
it was it it just felt like the right
platform for me because I it's funny
when you say I don't think people know
you I feel like I built a fan base
entirely on accessibility
yeah I know I guess I'm speaking from
the calm as a comic but wait a minute if
my fans know me who doesn't know me just
my haters yeah your haters don't know
you love me that's what I'm saying but I
find you as a figure that is like loved
by fans and hated by fans at the same
time you had such a tumultuous like just
like so many people like you know it was
it was actually cool to hate name cuts
right I actually jumped on that they had
an episode where they make it they make
reference to yes like wow that's super
famous yes I loved it I loved even the
hazing
I loved the family guy stuff for SNL
whoever was taking a shot at me like
Barinholtz did something years ago and
ended up online the only time it started
to ping me in a way that was negative
was when my family and my fans were
starting to feel like they had to defend
me right right and that was tricky that
was hard but the rest of it I'm totally
serious I secretly as a non
controversial kid growing up as somebody
who didn't make waves I was pretty
milquetoast right in some ways I was
creating this image that was like hey
man if people love and hate you that's
better because then they're they're
keeping you out there they're talking
about you or they're protecting you so
you were and so you you see you say you
grew up a nerd
well not so much a nerd just in
introvert you know I wish I was and
they're not people that what I mean to
say so if you don't know you very are
very introverted yeah yeah it's that's
always been kind of part of me the
outgoing character came out on stage
stage right and the rest of it was a lot
of isolation when I was a kid a lot of
anxiety a lot of panic attacks and not
feeling very good about myself as a
person and yet finding that I could from
what I was starting in standup that was
bleeding into my life yeah so starting
young it was like a lot of insecurity a
lot of like you know what made you what
then what gave you the courage to be
like let me try this onstage I knew I
wanted to do stand-up when I was like 12
oh I was watching SNL I was watching I
would sneak up watch the Johnny Carson
and I didn't know what half the jokes
meant really but I loved him I loved
that guy I loved seeing how he operated
I like when a joke went wrong and then
he came out of character and kind of
like took the piss out of himself he was
the best at bombing you know I've
actually heard I know if it's true that
some of those jokes were meant to bomb
that he wrote stuff in there that he
could then have asides yeah and I loved
that get a great look like that looked
to camera like well that one didn't work
yeah yeah and for me it's like any time
I've done specials where people have
heckled it probably has always stayed in
ORS on the album because I like that I
like that it's like it shows that you're
fallible and that we're all you know
we're gonna come back and tag you but in
that moment it you you you become very
real and you become very open to people
really understanding what makes you tick
because you've come out of the act and
now you're dealing with somebody
directly right and so so then you're
young you're watching Carson and then
you decide like you knew at that moment
I want to do this yes and it was like 16
was it before 16 that you decided to try
to go on stage or when I was 16 i okay
so when I started high school I was
drama I was in Boston Arlington
Massachusetts where I grew up and I
started doing drama and I did plays I
did like West Side Story and in grease
and all these plays who are you in
grease I was Danny Zuko
don't get attitude of course you were
Danny
oh my Moony you know I had the hair man
yeah I had the hair it's the one thing
that's still sticking around too for
yeah yeah you were in you you were you
were a singer I was you you were like
you remind me a Tupac right now that
people didn't know that a lot of street
cred in our only thought I'll play it
but I was doing plays and I loved it and
I found that it was an escape it was
actually comedy was more of I liked that
I didn't have to feel so afraid as I
felt kind of off stage yeah I hit the
stage it was like everything was there
kind of there we're getting there as
years went by and then with someone you
uh so I know doing the plays and stuff
it's like there's something about that
what you're still collaborating and
you're doing someone else's work but I
know that there's always that pull to be
like I'll let me do my own thing yeah
and the first time you do that it is
such a magical experience and the first
time I did it was so unexpected enough
ever told you I was at catch a rising
star in Cambridge Massachusetts David
Cross used to have like an open might
open mic like sketch night cross comedy
and what you would do is you would sign
up and then you would show up the week
after it's kind of like what kill Tony
does now which is you sign up you show
up and then they randomly they picked a
name okay one so I went a couple of
weeks and watched and was like can I
even do this I don't know if I can get
up there and and you know hold my own I
could play a character in a play well he
went up on stage the third week I was
there and he went through the list and
about the fifth or sixth person he said
okay where's earnest Glen
long pause I knew this guy didn't show
my hand went up he goes you're earnest
when I said yes and he goes alright my
intro all of it all the way from the
fifth row earnest Glen that was my first
set ever and it as earnest Glen as there
is Glen yeah
earnest Glen wherever I try to find him
on Facebook over the years and I want to
thank a man you didn't show up and you
set my career in motion Thank You Ernest
Glen it's also in the name that I used
to when I check into hotels which now I
like Glenn Ernestina so you go up yeah
yeah was it and I'm sure the cuz I
always find that the first time you do
is there's like no fee even if you have
fear there's something like it just
works did you have a good set it's
really what I'm asked um probably cuz I
didn't have any time to be nervous
because I didn't know I was going up so
better perfect and I don't know how you
are about when you get to your venue but
for me from that moment all the way from
for 29 years
I like being late and walking in and
they're like you're up right now I don't
I don't like sitting around and thinking
about the show or I don't need to write
everything down again it's not my that's
not my system I want to walk in and have
them go you're late come on let's go
let's get up there right now I'm better
like that a little frantic and a little
bit unsure that's good so you didn't all
right so then by the way you're doing a
great job man what you like this III
know this guy I've also had the pleasure
of working with and workaholics and all
this in it's like to be able to sit here
in kibitz with you about all these
because this inside baseballs I guess
when I say that people don't know you I
realized and I don't know you I want to
know more about was only me but you know
but this is like I'm where these guys
it's like I'm around and if I hear
people talking about another person I'm
like well do you have you talked to him
do you know this guy like what's up
because like I say your career has been
so like there are very few comics that
have reached the success level right
that you had there was a certain time
where was like you know was like you
know yeah it got really bought it got
really bonkers right yeah it does the
insecure guy next thing you know you're
dating Jessica Simpson you're dating no
chick from what just like tens bombshell
well you gotta remember something I also
was a kid that never had a date or
really never had a girlfriend so there
was a period in my life where I was like
yeah I just got caught up in the entire
thing but fortunately I could always
come back to stand up stand up always
reset me and made me kept me honest
because stand up you know it's like you
can't if Fame don't matter after two
minutes if you're not hitting us with
some jokes you're [ __ ] dead that's
true you suck in fact you suck more
because we really gave it up for you and
now you are mailing it in or you
just suck it's even worse because it's
like yeah that that crushed that that
thing that happens once you when someone
goes all right everybody Dane Cook and
everybody sucks I remember I remember at
the Laugh Factory by the way this is
this is a few years ago okay and I
remember seeing a group of kids and I
said it and I was something that guy
said everybody you were after me
everybody Dane Cook and I saw I could go
right now but there's another guy behind
him like this oh this guy you're from
Boston you're 16 you did it you knew you
wanted to do it okay and then I want to
get back to answering your question
about because I feel differently about
what I think people know of me and we're
gonna meet in the middle by the end of
this podcast that's exactly stay with us
I know because we're gonna first caller
from Texas Larry King called in with a
question
Mike hobo game yeah everything comes
full circle okay so where are we on the
timeline wait okay now you know you can
do this up here when when did you go up
as Dane Cook I went up the next time the
very next open mic which was a few
months later but I don't remember that
you weren't know somebody nobody was
like no but I but I my first hater ever
in in the industry was David Cross not
like me and I overheard him saying it he
said he said something disparaging like
like yeah that guy and he shouldn't even
be in here that you know it was like he
just didn't like my shtick does that
kind of fuel you um even at a young
agent well I'd been used to it from
elementary school up I always felt like
I was getting dig dad I had a lot of
things like I had bad acne when I was in
junior high cystic acne which was it
sucked it was gross and I was already
loathing myself now I've got mountains
of pus growing on my face like you
already hate yourself so let's give him
some puss yeah but they push this to the
limit let's see if this kid can break
before he's Liberty
so here I am getting like you know
hammered bully basically and probably
actually more so myself like beating
myself up and then now I'm introduced to
like Oh in the industry wherever you're
at you're gonna have people that like
you're you're out of vogue to them
already yeah so it prepared me for what
you almost what you almost want to thank
that sixth-grade bullied like hey thanks
dude because now I'm prepared for the
business you know what the great thing
is that sixth grade bully wrote me years
and years later in apologize oh sweet
you know and then he's like become
famous all your bullies who like I used
to bully that yeah I should have been
like this you know what two tickets for
you meet me in an alley behind the Wang
in Boston and just well [ __ ] I was just
saying to thank those girls that I tried
to get with early on right all that
rejection prepared me for Hollywood
it really did prepare me for like going
to auditions and them saying like no no
wait that one yes you know so alright so
David Cross hates you
you know so he's the first guy that set
you on this path yeah well people are
gonna hate me yeah yeah it was like okay
welcome to welcome to show business it's
great up there but it's still yeah it's
still a funky gig and and just for the
record I stabbed comedian just still
like above anybody else my favorite
people on earth we are complex there is
a lot of dark corners there's a lot of
like reasoning for why we do what we do
why we need to but I I adore comics and
I grew up loving them so yeah every once
while somebody comes along and spanks me
but I don't really hold it against
anybody you know II mean I never took it
that personal yeah you know I just
realize it's just a complex guy with a
lot of emotions and a lot of feelings so
if people don't necessarily know you
like the comics or people income they
don't know you have this quirk about
your these quirks about yourself cuz now
I'm thinking right now it's like this
thing about you where you're like I want
to go right on stage when you get to the
thing that might be mistaken by some
people is like oh this guy just wants to
bump everybody and go you know cuz he's
like you know the big guy but well your
thing is like I need to get on stage
right now yeah I just I'm gonna I gotta
get this out I just meant for my show
it's not even necessarily Chi I went
through my bump years I mean everybody
does everyone
you know we can pick a name that like
five years ago said ooh and be bummed
and then he's now he's bumping people so
everybody goes through a little bit of
bump king only The Laugh Factory
I never went on the road ever in the
road but I'm saying like Wednesday in LA
I mean where there's so many people here
and I didn't even do it at the improv or
at the store but if I came into the
factory
Jamie had set a precedent with me which
is like when you come in you're the
belle of the ball I want you to come in
and make sure that you feel and I
probably at a young albeit naive age
coming into superstardom let some of
that go to my head and as years passed I
was like yeah that's I don't want to do
that yeah you hit 40 and you're like
what am i doing
yeah it's like I'm gonna have enemies
regardless but I don't want to make them
because somebody's just trying to do
their spot and then go to you know
in-and-out burger for that all right let
me dig it on this and we can keep
jumping back in the school I like I like
linear but LCD 35 you're killing me
right now we'll keep it in water when I
think about the material that that
connected with people I feel like the
material that I've done especially maybe
over the last 10 years has been so much
more introspective and I give anything
it's like I was up on stage reading a
letter from a hater that told me my
parents died of cancer to get away from
my shitty comedy that was the exact
email yeah so I turned that newer
routine on absolute yesterday talked
about my mom dying talked about these
things that were like you know happening
and for real so where I'm sitting I'm
like well if people want to know me it's
all in the comedy right you know I
cheated on my girlfriend when I was
younger I did a whole bit about cheating
and it was like for me I felt like I'm
giving you access to like my flaws and
the things that I've done like you that
you know that have been missteps right I
thought you might be right but I feel
like it's always been I've been a little
bit more candid than what I think I see
sometimes with other comics that are
very veiled behind their routine I know
but it's like I think what I think the
hard part as I'm thinking about this
more is that you know you got to a point
where you were so famous that it's
almost hard to even hang out with people
that aren't as famous as you I mean it's
it's because I even see that like I'm
even talking about another level of like
if you're a headliner it's kind of hard
to hang out with an open mic er because
you're talking about different things in
a different way like it's a different
life experience so I mean and you like I
mean you were like at the stratosphere I
mean I remember listen man and there was
a time in LA where was like going to
Dublin's and it was like you know yeah
it was like you had to see Dane Cook it
was that kind of link yeah you were just
like it was just a dynamic source of
like you know and I just you know I felt
that it was in an inmate's MySpace crowd
of young people you connect it with
these people right and it was coming up
with a college-aged crowd right locked
into them and they were supporting me
and it was favorable and I just rode the
wave with them all the way to where it
would go yeah and what's you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you did but then what happens is
you know you have comics who would be
like because that's what you did is very
similar to say like Larry the Cable Guy
you know he knows crowd right I'm saying
he knew his crowd I got a brilliant guy
yeah you know but he knew but then
Outsiders would be like ah he's doing
this dumb thing is like no he's not he's
talking to a specific crowd and he knows
how to talk to him and that's what you
were doing by the way I same thing with
me but I'm the person also so I was on
the other side of it going like oh this
yeah this I'm sick of this face man this
guy needs to do by the way you know the
only time you've ever said anything to
be about my comedy I'll never forget it
this is great it was I was doing a joke
about Pacific Rim you know the guy they
pull out a sword and it's important I'm
like you're putting the thorn out now
open with the sword and you came out you
mean you were like you're doing that
Pacific Rim job you don't even believe
it man don't do that anymore I did say
that and I was like oh I knew that you
really meant that dick to the point
where you had to go I remember it but I
was like I was like oh this guy is not
being authentic at this point you
thought that and I was like but I
thought what I was
like that's the kind of relationship
that you know you want we would like to
think that all comics have but it's like
again I really feel like you got into a
stratosphere that you were just outside
of that bubble that it was hard for
people to relate it was hard for people
to like understand your quirks do you
feel misunderstood it's basically when
I'm asked um I think that there was
probably a period where I felt
misunderstood because I still kind of
misunderstood myself I was I didn't have
a playbook for stardom I didn't have a
playbook for grief theory there's no
Learning Annex class not gonna be a
superstar in very few people you can
have a conversation with about it
because nobody has felt that same
pendulum swing of like hey you're
hitting a level that nobody really
understands and you're also hitting a
rock bottom that many people won't hit
until years later with their parents or
with you know the loss that you know we
all face at some point so imagine I'm in
that I'm embroiled but and again this is
where it's so interesting to hear how it
looked on the outside the support that I
started getting from the generation of
comics that already made it and didn't
need or have anything to gain or lose
from me and then the comedian's that
were kind of in my wake that appreciated
what I did and I could kind of mentor
once I had enough success and failure to
try to help that was great that was
actually my kind of protective armor the
comics that I was coming up with outside
of my graduating class out of Boston or
New York what was happening was this
they were getting hammered every day
with questions from like DJs and they
would call me and tell me this and
complain to me like what are you doing
Dayne did why how come your numbers
aren't and people started to resent that
like like people at my level that were
also as talented or sometimes even more
talented well they weren't getting the
just do because we know it's not a line
you're not next yeah it doesn't it's not
a deli no it's a number 75 your fame is
ready it doesn't work like it does not
work like that and so when that all
happened and I was holding onto these
you know people that you know and I'm
trying to think like Richard Lewis you
know somebody I grew up watching a
nature
like I love that guy and he's always
been like a champion and then Jerry
Lewis you know as I got to know
so I'm getting to know like you know I
did shows years back Buddy Hackett and I
felt like a simpatico with the guys that
had already made it and by the way had
already hit their peaks and already hit
lows before it levels out which is kind
of where I'm at now and becomes just
like this is who you are it's not yeah
it's like I stand and deliver
I don't need to be the shiny new thing
anymore did it happy with it played 100
arenas now I just want to connect with
people I want to fun I want to pay the
rent I just want to have a blast but
that period of time it when I think
about like oh five and when everything
you had just gotten when did you get to
LA LA was 98 okay so you got to LA in 98
yep let's go back to the timeline okay
let's it is the point where you're
talking about right now because I want
people to know we had sound effects of
like because this lead up to okay like
this duh
pinnacle like it's like you're not
you're just flying high that's 2005
until like you know whenever that was
right now so so 98 you get to LA 98 came
to LA I was actually in San Francisco I
did the San Fran comedy contest and that
actually by the way that San Francisco
comedy contest that was probably one of
the first times where like there's a
line drawn in the sand between like
mainstream comedy which you would be
considered good mainstream I'm gonna
please the audience right because that's
what we're [ __ ] doing we're
entertaining and then these people this
let you know the alternative Doug
Stanhope type those those yeah because
he was on my time yes it was in your top
five Doug Stanhope Mitch Hedberg yeah
you know so a very different you know
show structurally we're three different
guys with different mentalities I'm up
it was fun and from there they a
producer saw me and said we're doing a
show with Betty White and we need
someone to play her grandson and I love
your comedy and I love your energy would
you come down never done a TV show never
been on a TV set Wow but I took the gig
and that's what got me to LA so I ended
up just coming here and living out of a
hotel and and doing this show and
learning comedy acting TV wise from
Betty White Wow
oh look at that yeah I did not know that
yeah so you did that as I was out here
and I was just kind of language I was
really languishing even with the show
because it was not a popular show no it
was a Saturday night 8:30 ABC show my
own family was like we're not [ __ ]
staying home to watch them hilarious
that you're like if you have the dream
to be on TV and you get on TV and you
think and then if people are still like
yeah and even yourself you start to go
oh this this actually isn't what I
wanted
it's not that it's not the end I'm not
done but I was also in a situation where
like I'm probably not very good at this
so at least I can learn without too much
judgment it wasn't on my shoulders it
was a Betty White show Marie Osmond
played my mom which was also mind
blowing yeah and it was just a place for
me to go and and try to figure out can I
can I be on this out of the of the you
know comedy spectrum can I can I do
acting and all that kind of stuff it was
in LA kept me here and I started going a
lot factory right Jamie saw me put me up
one night and he was just like hey
listen this can be your home base and
here's what kept me in LA I was ready to
go back to New York and Boston I wanted
to go back to New York in Boston I was I
was homesick bad I wasn't good on the
road for long periods of time
my anxiety would kick in and I just
needed to be home home was like safe
gotcha
but I'm like okay I'm going up here at
the Laugh Factory and after about two
months I said I'm gonna stay two months
I'm gonna go home and then I realized
something was happening which was really
exciting which was I was the only East
Coast mentality kind of comic in a place
that still had a lot of showcase guys
from a little bit earlier back who had
their white-hot moment so I was like a
new guy from a new generation and if I
went back to New York I was gonna be one
of many that were coming up so I stayed
here in in said I'm gonna be a Boston
comic in LA yeah and again it kept me
here I for the first five six seven
years I thought I'm gonna go home next
year and I'm still here still here I
know I said as long as there's work I'm
gonna stay so then around so they're
doing you're at the Laugh Factory you're
crushing there and then like then
because it was because then when did
Dublin start after that because 95 I
remember doubloons started like around
oh one because I think it had like a six
five or six year run yes you okay so you
were here
so you're in LA for five six years yeah
just doing the Laugh Factory that's it
just doing laughs factory in and the the
humble beginnings of the computer stuff
which was you know AOL existed the
internet existed
it wasn't until 2000 till I finally
hatched a plan to build a web site in a
web presence yes that's that's not okay
and here's a fun fact there was only one
other person in comedy doing that at the
time there was only one other guy with a
dinette I get a lot of the credit but I
always share it with this guy there was
one other guy who was doing it and his
site was cool and he was interacting
that was Joe Rogan ah yeah Rogan had a
cool site yeah it was an alien freak an
East Coast guy yeah yeah yeah something
in the water man back yeah it's like and
so I had my site go and Joe had his
going and then it was nobody else it was
like a lot of bands and and not a lot of
comedy or comedians yes so then it was
like yeah you know I do I remember your
site I remember it being like this
dynamic thing yeah it was like the first
flash yeah it was like wow
it opened my whole life savings on it I
made I had had $40,000 to my name in 98
and I found Lenny Kravitz his website
and I said who made this and I went and
I found the company and then I had my
manager reach out and he goes this is
gonna be thirty five thousand dollars
you don't want to do this and I was like
I need to do this this is gonna be the
portal this is it so my whole life
savings that I had to go back on the
road he even imagined now spending that
money on a website oh my god okay so you
all right you got your website and then
myspace started and then you just run
the ground floors ready myspace is
starting Napster is starting right and
in my first Comedy Central special which
they were was gonna air once or twice
you know they were saying where there's
a couple of times they'll be on like
late at night all that they started
playing that non-stop college kids were
watching so all those things were
happening in the 2000s is a perfect
storm everything happened at the right
time in it really did and you you were
ready for
though I was ink I was rare you how
about this were you ready for it
I believed I was because the pipe dream
was coming to fruition and that's all
that instills you with confidence oh
this this is actually working because I
thought it would but that doesn't it's
like that doesn't prepare you for the
responsibility that comes with that as a
as a business person because they each
are in a business you're making people
money right you're paying other people's
mortgage based on how your film does
they could lose their house if you don't
capitalize so I wasn't ready for the
enterprise just just being on that
sitcom I was I was learned as I went you
know the stand-up was the only thing I
felt like a real control over but all
the stuff that was happening around it
was just like dude I was just riding a
wave I really was I was just boogie
board and out there and trying to figure
out wave was like that way that
Gilligan's Island wave yeah the surfer
that he had to ride a wave all the way
to back to Hawaii it was that kind of
wave it was it was it was pretty
unbelievable for to go from where I had
started to now I can call my mom up and
say that everything I told you that I
hoped would happen is is happening and
I'm free I'm freaking out
my anxiety everything was like I was
getting tested on so many fronts and
that's before [ __ ] hits the fan and
here's what I said earlier today to
somebody who was asking me about comedy
I said when you make it to a level of
success to where you're a household name
that's actually what you're actually
achieving is a moment in your career
where you're about to meet everybody
that doesn't like you and there's way
more of those people yeah and they're
gonna have a stronger opinion sometimes
more than the people that love you that
just kind of like you know hey we we dig
you weren't really into all the drama we
just come see your show but haters work
overtime yes they do right I totally get
that I totally see that so like you know
so now you get into this like now you're
you know you're super famous that's pop
and now everything's like aha tilt boom
yeah yeah yeah and
in a carnival I'm living in an amusement
park sighting and I never know when the
phone rings what producer or director or
Lorne Michaels or somebody's gonna be on
that phone who's like hey man I'm a fan
I wanted to talk to you yeah then you
and then you got to a point where all
right so you're now you're doing your
your your specials like the so you did
the Comedy Central special now I always
remember this story you tell me about
like you had a vision for the Comedy
Central special said like we should
willy tape this tape an hour you know
you know and you did that right right
okay so I was selling harmful if
swallowed out of my trunk before I had a
record deal for two years I recorded at
the last stop in Houston on the on a dad
player that they had a dad recorder oh
yeah yeah oh yeah and so I ended it out
here with a buddy Eric Schwartz no Eric
yeah Eric edited harmful if swallowed
Wow I brought the materials back he was
working at premier radio cutting their
commercials I said I need a computer too
I know computers but I don't edit like
he goes bring it over to a premier Eddie
will sneak in on weekends so we would
use this little laminate and we'd get in
there and we edited harmful sold it out
of my trunk you know wherever I went for
a couple years before Jack Vaughn and
Comedy Central came in and said we give
you a record deal which is also a
interesting quick story which I said how
many am I gonna sell do you think I'm
selling a lot out of my trunk right they
said 8,000 they said 8,000 tops I said I
think it's gonna be more they go the
comedy albums dead corner unquote he
goes comedy almost dead he's back then
back then he said this is a it's a
promotional piece it's it's don't think
it's dead well okay well what do I do
I make a better deal cuz I'm like oh
since it's dead it's dead Dan yeah just
give me the you know everything over
9000 you give me sold like 90,000 yeah
in the first week and so what is
happening at that point is you do a
Madonna numbers at this point everything
yeah everything everything is getting
it's like doubling and tripling and it's
getting insane in terms of like just the
sheer amount of activity that goes
around keeping the plates spinning once
they start and yeah I was definitely
free
but I was also it was like bliss because
I was have I was I had access now to
comedy heroes that I came up with that
actually wanted to talk to me and
correspond with me and that's one of the
best parts of this job this yeah yeah
you know anymore as prickly as comedians
can be and you know and we're
competitive as [ __ ] all get-out when
we're talking shop or when we're like
needing the community it's it's pretty
amazing yeah the community is there for
you I agree with this is it's an
interesting Brotherhood yeah and it's
like the community sometimes you know we
can we can hurt each other and I went
through that with Louie and all that
stuff it's like stuff happens every once
in a while that's like unfortunate and
kind of out of well not out of control
because I think he had some control of
how it got out of control but the
goodwill that came from that is like
friendships I've made for life well I
thought you were great on that episode
of his show were like you know he was
coming to him as himself coming to talk
to you about getting tickets yeah I
thought that seemed between you guys I
would have loved to have seen that be a
real life like yeah on the couch
interview or like this like if he had a
podcast and he had you want and you guys
were just really shooting a [ __ ] I
thought I thought it was a real genuine
moment right there
listen I I knew I knew why that was
happening at the time I knew why I had
been targeted by him and I knew that he
was frustrated because I knew that lucky
Louie gotten cancelled and I think a lot
of he thought that was gonna be like his
moment
you know not knowing what he would do
later which was more dynamic and so he
was frustrated and retaliation came out
like a few weeks after that cancellation
and it just was a perfect storm and he
was at the factory and it just it wasn't
a it wasn't a good start with him and I
knew in fact I knew when he said that I
had taken stuff from him that very night
I wrote him an impassioned email I still
have it and I still have his response
and I basically said Louie please don't
do this
this is something comics do at the back
of the club and we work it out if
there's something that's like crossover
or whatever but you know don't put your
boot on my neck because your respect to
your a Comics comic and he was not ready
to act we asked at that time it
wasn't until the episode were he had
been back tracking it and saying things
and interviews I don't think he really
took but I think the parallel thinking
and so the show was a way to kind of
heal all that oh that's good and and by
the way and I say this and I'm not
trying to sound like maudlin or like
what happened with him and the other
story of like these other comedians and
these woman like what happened to me and
why don't speak out on it unless I'm
with friends is like that's way more
severe and serious than what happened
with with me there it still hurt you
know what I mean and it hurt my fans and
family but in comparison it's like he he
hurt careers over there in ways that
were like I would not even understand
you know what I mean right so I always
have to kind of let people know that
that I don't make it all about me we're
talking about me but like I don't
subscribe to the idea that I was a
victim in that I just think that it was
it was like to people that were not on
the same page whatsoever so you're so
that around this time they're like you
know this does the you know I said all
the haters are coming out it's like
superstar Fame and then that's when you
had some tragedies in your life right
you know it's the that's it's like
that's how life is like a [ __ ] up
sometimes that's where it's like here's
everything but we're gonna take this
right it's it's that pendulum swing
because however far it swings in the
positive direction it's gonna swing
equally into the other side I feel like
life's like that not everybody has that
same philosophy but that's kind of the
way I see the rhythm of the ebb and flow
of life or at least my experience and
now do you find yourself then waiting
for like you know something good is
happening do you find yourself like ah
where's the the chair gonna get pulled
from under me I think it's coming I
think that I'm a little cynical as I've
gotten older but because we've all you
know we all get stung or we we all get
spanked you know from the experiences
that we we put ourselves into is as
performers as artists but and I don't I
don't dwell I don't think to too much
about it I'm just like okay I just off
to the next show man I'm off to the next
you know possibility I love I love the
rebuilding process now yeah I was gonna
say cuz I remember okay so
I recall when you did the vicious circle
right you know so I thought to myself
what an ambitious thing you know because
it's like I to me I thought that that
was the kind of thing where if you're a
Dane Cook fan this is the special way
you tell people remember that guy I was
telling you about you gotta watch this
right you know and then after that like
what cuz like that was like that was
that at that time the biggest thing he'd
ever done yeah so that was like oh six
that aired it was the biggest thing was
the biggest venue I'd ever played it was
my homecoming to Boston you know we did
it at Boston Garden so it was important
to me on so many levels the city that
you know that kind of brought me up and
believed in me just there was a lot of
pressure there to go in called MALDI
Marty Calder who had directed some
comedy specials that I loved like Carlin
in the round in 77 and I was fortunate
enough that he was signed on and was
like I'll direct this the experience of
that night ready this is how literally
that day was the tipping point my mom
was already sick she was already
starting to fight cancer we we we knew
it was serious wasn't sure if she was
gonna like maybe she was so vibrant we
thought maybe like she'll fight this
fight it yeah yeah yeah she couldn't
come because she was too ill to travel
so I do that special I have the set of
my life I mean I'm at the top of my game
I feel like I'm using not all the tools
I'm using now but like enough of the
tools to make it interesting hopefully
and then I go back to my hotel room
and I break down I'm sad because I'm my
mom was not there for and she came to
countless another huge she used to come
get drunk on clueless and brewers and
heckle me
so your first bully was mom my mom would
heckle me from the back of the comedy
connection do the thing about when you
caught me having sex with your father
somebody else you go hey shut up and I
go hey no you shut up that's my mom
she became like part of the yeah the
repertoire so her not being there was
like made me want to be even better
because I took the raw footage and I
flew to Florida the next morning and
showed her wow you know so that that was
the beginning of the personal strife
right you know mom then dad gets sick
with cancer a week after my mom died my
dad called me and said we need to talk i
sat down with him I was like you're not
sick right he's like I I have prostate
cancer so nine months both parents right
gone and then stuff with my brother and
then loui so it was like I had gone from
the wave had gotten big gotten crazy
even the backlash and the hate before
all that happened I didn't mind I like
kind of being Darth Vader right right
thought it was more interesting yeah
because I felt interesting when for many
years I didn't feel like I had that kind
of swagger so I'm enjoying it until my
mom got sick right because because at
that point you're like then it wasn't
funny because you're like [ __ ] all the
haters because I got my foundation I got
my family my core and literally and then
that's taken away from ya I had haters
since I was like a kid so I didn't I
accepted the fact that in my life more
people probably are not going to be on
the same page with me so I was seeking
out true friendships from a very early
age and then in stand-up I was prepared
for all of that it didn't hurt until it
hurt and it hurt when I'm trying to deal
with my family I can't focus the same
amount of energy on like keeping the
structure together because I don't I'm
hurt I don't care I just want to you
know protect my my family my mom and my
dad you know my little sister who you
know I work with to this day she means
the world to me she's like my left arm
so all that stuff is happening and then
spirals
after vicious circle and it was gonna be
it was gonna be a tough few years yes
God so yeah so it's like mom dad dies
brother steals this stuff happens with
Louie the haters rampa my mentor died a
year after my high school drama teacher
Frank Roberts wouldn't wouldn't have
been here without him he put me on stage
he was the first person to
still confidence in me so he passed away
and then you know I started there was
even a couple of comics local comics in
Boston that were kind of like my core
guys and they either one vanished and
the other one passed away so it was like
yes everything was getting really
[ __ ] real
and that was what year was that that's
that was all like oh six two like Oh a
208 and then the brother stuff was like
oh eight to ten or all right where I was
dealing with all that so everything in a
four year period was happening and I
still hadn't dealt with grief I didn't
know how clueless I just knew my things
because you just feel betrayed by life
oh yeah like you just yeah I mean I get
that it was nuts I I thought I was gonna
be broke again
I'd already hit the this upper echelon
and made the most that I thought I'm
safe for the rest of my life okay now
I'm not and I'm already coming down the
other side of what might be the biggest
summit Ronda career I'm gonna have a
marathon career I'm gonna be doing this
when I'm 90 but I'm gonna make this
amount of light yes she's right so it's
like yeah that nest egg was gone now
fortunately for me when all that stuff
happened my brother for people that I
don't know my brother stole my money my
brother stole millions upon millions of
dollars from me he was my business
manager well but I always should say
myself I'm like well jeez
like if somebody can steal that amount
of money from you that you like if you
had only let's say you had 10 million
okay if somebody stole five you gonna
see half your money's gone you would
think that right I'll get you a thing
but I guess but then you're not thinking
right because this is your brother's
trusting you trust it he betrayed me
with love yeah yeah the worst kind of
betrayal yeah but again I think this
what makes you a little prickly around
people I think yeah I think that I think
your trust issues if you have trust
issues that certainly did help I didn't
I didn't have a lot of trust issues for
most of my life as well you know and I
mean that was there was always there was
either people that were champions and
like made me feel safe and then there
was a lot of people that made me feel
frantic and there was more chaos around
me so now here was somebody that I grew
up with that was fan literally the
closest person to me right and he was I
say the piranhas of Hollywood didn't get
me but my brother was the devil
so it was it was insane he capsized me
and I thought okay if I don't have more
success like I'm gonna have to spend the
rest of my life really just like
charging away again like Full Tilt in
sin not saying no the power of no which
is good to have and I could say make
sure you know you're at a nice on
commercial like high they had you two
crazy pair of glasses and I was like
ride Goliath yeah and they have me on
the roller coaster my hair's so I did I
sold out for a minute to try to make
rent but I took the little the money
that he couldn't steal was money that I
because he had been sending me false
bank accounts for many years false
statements and I wasn't going to the
bank and looking cuz I was like course
not thinking like damn we're doing good
I'm just focusing on the creativity and
the fan building and all that stuff so
what happens is I have a little bit of
money in stocks that he couldn't take he
can't just pull that out it was like a
longer process so I took the last you
know couple hundred thousand dollars
that I had to my name and I invested in
the arenas so the arenas I rented Oh
I rented a hundred arenas over a year
because my goal was once he was in jail
I wanted to make back everything he
stole in a year Wow so I rented it does
what I do I run an arena for whatever
seven eight thousand dollars on an off
night no basketball game I take the door
you know I did merch I take the door and
I literally would sit with my manager
and I'd be like how'd we do he's like
alright well tonight it's $250,000 I was
like rent another yeah call ahead let's
rent these two let's write this now East
rented be arenas see or didn't matter
you know what you know what let me taste
some what's amazing about this as like
as a I'm in the business as a comic you
know you think that like how do you get
an arena tour so people think that
there's some kind of person there's a
there's like a there's some that guy
calls and goes I'm ready mister arena
this is mister anyone do this I know
you're saying yeah I did it myself
yeah what I learned was arenas were just
like building hall yeah yeah just like
yeah you could've done a Kinson Yetta
there I wanted
it didn't it didn't matter you can just
jerk off in the middle of an empty space
for 75 grand somebody go and now but it
was starting lineup for your it was at
that point that I started feeling safe
again you know I started feeling like a
feeling of and I felt a feeling of
independence but I never felt because I
was I I was so close to somebody that
was so toxic and I didn't know it so
once he was gone I was like oh man
there's so many things that I'm I'm more
keen to because I was now standing on my
own in a way that he made me feel like I
needed him right right well that was on
purpose so those my desires
yeah he was my design rooming me yeah
yes some way to keep me complacent right
in no no more contact I haven't I
haven't spoken to him since the day he
went missing oh you went missing who are
missing for two weeks and the police
arrested him and he went to jail for I
think he got eight years and his wife
who is in cahoots God for Wow
yeah so I've never spoken to him but I
still speak with his son I'm very close
with my nuts good yeah you know and then
so this now this leads us to like I
remember how different that next special
you did that's right it was like it was
like it was just at the Laugh Factory
yeah what one camera yeah just a dark
black background
yeah type of thing and you just is just
you on stage that was the first time I
thought to myself who dis guys doing
something interesting like I really
thought that was the first time I was
like oh you really there's some
vulnerability going on here that's this
beyond all this stardom it was a weird
gift that my parents passing gave me
which was hey you can you can now share
something that's really very very
personal and hopefully that's gonna help
me to build my career out in a new way
and why did I want to do that
interestingly enough when I was younger
George Carlin people knew George Carlin
as the hippie-dippie weatherman right he
did the hippy dippy weatherman for a lot
of years and a lot of years and it
finally Harlan
on a late night show might have been The
Tonight Show is amazing clip if you can
find it on on YouTube and he's standing
there with a cardboard cutout of himself
as the hippie to be weatherman but now
he's like looking more like Carlin and
he comes on he's a living shaman George
Carlin brings the cardboard cutout and
he starts off and he's like he goes on a
lot of you know him this guy you know
other people laughs I know you know him
too and then he took the cardboard
cutout and he dropped it and he goes but
I'm not doing that guy anymore and I
hope that you'll come with me on this
new ride let's start and he reinvented
himself almost instantaneously by
killing the hippy dippy weatherman so
you feel like the college bro the bro
down to grow up you know Ichi butthole
Dane Cook time to grow up got he's gone
yeah and that was the first time you're
like yeah when I ceased to be a child I
put away childish things you know it was
time to really embrace that I'm an adult
man I've got you know good things that
have happened sure I can share stories
that you that you'll say wow I mean
that's something that is so rare to
experience and I can make that funny but
I can also talk about the dark corners
of life you know what I mean I made it
through I made it through all that stuff
man my trials by fire all happened at
once in a bonfire they were hitting you
both here's how I knew it was intense I
finally got a therapist four and a half
years later and after my first hour he
didn't say a word and then when I
finally finished he went like this it
was still in therapy
I still do it from time to time like I
did it like real hardcore for years yeah
I'm doing it now I enjoy Lee I really
enjoy it very helped I think it's the
greatest gift yet yourself well I find
it's the one person that I don't have to
I actually don't have to worry about
their feelings right and I can just kind
of just be like I need to say this and
this is what's going on and I could just
be funny as I need to be so I really
enjoy I think everyone should go to
therapy have you read The Four
Agreements
no I haven't seen it I haven't read down
man okay well you know we can have
another conversation yeah that's that's
one that's a as a man like this is a
book that I think it's a simple quick
read but it's it's impacted my life in a
major way
so I'm sitting with my therapist and I'm
doing all this work and I nice and I
take my first break from comedy first
time in 15 years that I took like a
legit I'm not gonna go on stage for
months and months and months which was
so weird
it just felt it's like a Wednesday and
you're like I'm supposed to be in and
what would happen is I I just have a
date and then at 11 o'clock at night the
girl be like man like your energy
cuz I was ready do a show so I'd be I'd
be doing shtick so here I am I'm like
I'm like living living a regular norm
having some normalcy which felt good and
not not as much was expected of me
because I wasn't as in demand and wasn't
you know the phone wasn't ringing off
the hook and that was that felt kind of
nice and then what I did was and maybe
you're doing the same thing
my goal was I'm gonna I want to work as
hard on myself as I ever have on my
career well that's what I did for that
time well you know what I learned what
I'm learning right now in therapy it's
like I'm just I'm learning the things
that I didn't know that I needed to work
on you know like setting boundaries you
know cuz that's the thing that I think
that is the hardest thing is like you
know you know just tell people no and to
like it and that'd be okay and so like
see I got past that I'm very good in it
oh no cuz you took me forever to get you
all my I miss I'm assertive to a fault
I think sometimes especially in this
town you know it's a weird town to be
assertive because assertive out here is
you're an [ __ ] and why it's because
I'm gonna tell you true I don't like
that or I don't learn is that's how you
learn to be okay with that that's the
thing I'm totally okay with that choice
is that you man I'm totally ok with
being unfiltered and blunt I call it
like whole crush level depths of honesty
in my life with also with myself when
I'm [ __ ] up
I take myself to task and in my stand-up
I do the same thing where it's like if
I'm not working as hard as I need to to
get to the point then I don't I don't I
don't I don't imagine myself in another
place in my life I say I'm just I'm
working comic and I'm not gonna be if I
don't get funnier
do you miss at all that level of the
fame that you were at um I here's what I
loved about the highest level of Fame
that I learned I loved that I could help
more people because when you're that
gigantic and you say hey I want to go to
Children's Hospital and I want to bring
all the DVDs from planes or I want to
people are like okay okay so suddenly
you're like whether it was going to Iraq
or doing USO stuff or I don't talk a lot
about the charity stuff I did but I had
access to a lot of people to help me and
so when you when that diminishes when
that starts to close what you're finding
is you're going you know what comedy
still feels like comedy a crowd still
feels like roud right but I may not get
the same kind of invites to where it's
like oh let me participate in doing
something that's actually changing the
community around me and that's very
important to me you know that's like one
of my that's one of the highlights of my
career and that's what even with all
this stuff happening again right now and
as it's being regenerated people
reaching out and being like hey can you
help me with a B and C that's what I
love that's great yeah man
you know it's like it's and then here
you are again you know talk about full
circle you've gone through your own
vicious circle of life now here you are
about to go on again this forty nine
city tour amazing you know probably
adding more things like they're I mean
are you are you are you super are you at
your most comfortable with yourself
right now I'm I'm like the happiest I've
ever been because going through
everything I went through when I was
younger and then experience saying you
know the the pains of life well finally
it was like about five years ago I'm
like hey you know what I didn't even
have any more parents that can die I'm
done every
I'm signing my own checks now I'm good
and so checking your bank account on
your phone now it's like which by the
way yeah that that actually that was
something I wish had been around at the
very very beginning she would have been
on the ground floor that you would have
been depositing your checks like people
would be like look at Cooke depositing
his checks on his phone like an [ __ ]
the high side of all of it yeah but
where I'm at now is somebody was like
why do I continue to do it at 30 years
in especially when there's all these new
people and I said well I said that's the
cycle you know there's other people that
are having their very unique moment of
superstardom or however ever it is right
and so that has value to go to that show
and support somebody who it's their
first time doing Madison Square Garden
aware that has so much value but there's
also value in coming to see somebody
whose pedigree is 30 years in yeah yeah
and I have like when I'm on stage now I
have so many more tools to tell a story
you see me all the time it's like I can
improv I can be irreverent I can I'm a
storyteller but I didn't want a word
Smith I loved vernacular a lot of jargon
that's your that's that's that's the
thing I would say I love training [ __ ]
but I like saying trepidation yeah I
like saying I'm [ __ ] trepidation yeah
yeah yeah so when I'm on stage and I can
go to all these different more tools in
my arsenal okay well I can just tell
more interesting stories but why it took
me so long to do this particular tour
was I just didn't want to lose the funny
I want it as much funny as people when
they saw a vicious circle or harmful or
whatever I didn't I don't want to be a
one-man show no disrespect to one-man
shows I don't want the maudlin part of
it yeah and so I wanted seriousness I
want to be able to be impactful but I
want to speak to this generation of
comedy fans that but I don't think
there's anything I grew up I personally
wouldn't mind seeing like an old-school
version of the one-man show with you
talking about some of the things in your
life these vulnerability this vulnerable
moment say listen if this tour doesn't
work and then [ __ ] assign me up
yeah you know bu back in Magic Mountain
no it's that's you know I've had some
interesting offers it's just not the you
know I've been asked to do Broadway it's
like I want to but not not yet
what did wait not it just this feels
right just you know this again this is
the first time this tour is the first
time that I've been out there and doing
it in a way that like I feel unbridled
mm I'm enjoying that I can bring so much
to the table and I don't have to worry
about what's off the table
so much anymore everything's kind of in
a nice little routine and rhythm that's
great man yeah which is why I'm
announcing my retirement right now this
tour and we knew you were doing it we
bring a cake out so I know you're like a
game or two people don't know about you
I know your gamer you know you know you
play video games but I but you know it's
funny when I when you told me you play
video games you say you played pub G I
knew that you were this guy that you're
on your thing you're like on the squad
leader you're the squad leader yeah I'm
I'm I'm a very competitive person when
I'm gaming whether it's online or board
games if I'm playing like you know code
names like I want to win I love love
competing so you like to battle royale
games that are out there right now okay
so I like playing I like that a rail I
never got it really fortnight which felt
like a Happy Meal come to life yeah I
don't know yeah yeah yeah it's like so
that that was not appealing to me is
that whole that whole element of the
game but I like the tactical of pub G
and then I tried blackout and I wasn't
into it
what that is so much better than pub G I
don't even get what you're saying right
now I'm gonna walk out of this like I
can break it down why why blackout fails
ready it doesn't fail it you can't lean
around a corner oh good you have to come
out
Wheatly straight back in that's [ __ ]
if you're in life hunting somebody would
you go like this there's one thing
yeah but the pub Jean Adaline and maybe
I'll come back the pub G rendering I
can't I can't stand bears it's throwback
ellipse records ridiculous it's like the
original unreal and everybody looks like
a like a green man everybody's like okay
it's not like choppy yes it's choppy I
can stand it Oh have you tried to know
how you tried the ape a pecks legend
lays pets legend
yeah I'm kind of digging now me too yeah
I think they toned down the cartoon this
a fortnight yes and they brought their
graphics of black ops III think it's my
favorite next to pub G but there's one
problem with it no leaning leaning
oh and no pros you can't go prone yeah
okay I'm a sniper oh I'm a sniper what
am I gonna do sit on a crate to sit on
boxes dad I want to lay down in the
grass okay all right they don't they
just put it out
update okay good legend what else try to
anthem which is kind of like destiny
which I know that you love destined
every time I can log on your honor
here's my problem with anthem that was
the [ __ ] roll out okay rise so choppy
you couldn't log in here to turn your
xbox so I've turned it back on that was
a big mistake on their part yeah but if
we want games to just work this apex
just worked you got on your playing
anthem anthem head yeah it's gonna be
good had problems out of the out of the
gate but apex it's like it feels like
titanfall you know I wish your Titans in
it but but those are the only things
that I've been playing really is the
Battle Royale you like those guys no no
I've never been in love sports but I
hate mad and in all those games yeah the
only game I really like to play sports
wise is the soccer I like you know I
like FIFA yeah because you have the most
control over what happens right these
other games it's a lot has to do with
like that the AI but I don't want to be
involved with that
you know what I hate the color green and
so I don't like any of those games I
think that's what it is I just hate
fields of green it's just not it's not
something I want to look at that's such
an odd hey man this is what we do for a
living odd observations yes green Wow
there's nothing better than saying
something people and you realize about
myself
Green I don't wanna look at a yellow
background either so it's like there's
certain colors that are appealing to me
and those colors are in pub G I got you
know I see that you're also still
keeping yourself in pretty good shape
I'm in the best shape of my entire week
but just about to say he better not say
like man 46 yeah here's what happens at
46 that I didn't realize you wake up in
the morning you look in the mirror and
you're like oh man my face needs to wake
up and then an hour later are you
looking at like oh [ __ ] I was awake you
know but but it if anything it's just it
motivates me to want to continue I work
out every day and yeah good for you I'm
Brian
you know I go I started boxing okay you
know which is here see your videos man
I'm trying my best
yeah I put up a video I'm Claudia and
then people are like you know like I
miss slowest hands on the plant you know
I'm not gonna name names but we know
plenty people posting boxing videos and
they're speeding them up to make it look
like they're faster listen to the music
in the background it's like it's like
Benny Hill which is one of my favorite
shows when I was a kid oh man me too a
boob would come out every once in a
while yeah yeah blown away and that's on
regular team regular like can you
imagine in this day and age right now
with me too and everything that's going
on firfer for Benny Hill to be on the
air there's no way that I show like that
would be on the air right all right
it would be just he just run by somebody
in the wind would make their tip pop out
and then that band antenna
today and then that music would kick in
in just somebody's boob would bounce
around really fast for a while that's
when I knew that I liked girls
Benny Hill Benny Hill when I was like
like it was a Wonder Woman okay yeah
that too you know she would just spin
around and all her clothes would come
off yeah and now we're in an age where
they want us to spin in the clothes just
come on what do you actually think about
like what do you think about this the me
to movement what do you what do you
think is it has it made you more
thoughtful how about that has it changed
your comedy cuz you're a bros bro
there'd be times when you when in your
younger years right that you had some
like not inappropriate but what I'm
saying yeah those guys stuff yeah yeah
sure I feel like I think that it's good
for the comedy world even though I know
some people would smash me for this and
say like no it's it's inhibiting people
from being able to know it's like okay a
lot of that material is old age thinking
and I feel like people need to be tough
we need to change as a civilization man
we're evolving we're equal it's like you
think about you going make women weren't
voting before 19 you know 60 it's like
insane to think that so much has
happened in such a little amount of time
that for me I as a person that never
really wanted to focus on saying things
that were so you know with vitriol right
I think I think it's good I think it's a
it makes the playing field more even
fair and I also think that it invites
more people in that are unique and very
different so I like it that's what I
thought was crazy about that game app
epics game by the way it's like you know
all the characters yeah
like all the characters was like this is
just one white guy I get to be the robot
it'll be a droid to at least have some
you know some but I feel like you know
as you start to do mature if you have
say sexist material or if you have like
something that's like you know anti you
know now I just feel like it's just
making us have to be more thoughtful
and I think that's okay like you don't
have to not talk about those rights but
just take some time to really develop it
yeah I think that there's still gonna be
somebody out there who's gonna set
themself apart and can say things that
are like holy [ __ ] moments yeah and
deliver it in a way that's like oh man
that that's true and it's still hardcore
but it's not it's not devaluing people
like if you look at some of the earlier
material like that we've seen many many
years ago so III think it's good for the
the populace I think it's good for
everybody that we're feeling more
equality and I think that's also good
for comedy because then we can dig it
each other a little bit more because
we're we know we're on a level plane
yeah yeah you're hitting on somebody who
when you're hitting somebody who's like
already marginalized just like that
that's that's even worse when I see that
happening
yeah good for you yeah well I mean I
don't know I think that but you do know
I know I just your therapist would say
but you I know I know why do you feel
that way I don't know man I just I'm
glad I'm really glad you came on and we
got to know a little bit more about your
I got a little bit of what more asking
me the question no no I mean because we
got to know a little bit more I don't
think you can learn about somebody in an
hour that's why I say just a little bit
okay so this is part one this is just
part one I want you to come on again
another time it will be even more
comfortable okay um and I wish you the
best on the tour and you know maybe
you'll see me out there on tour with mr.
Cooke I just asked you would you I said
on record lovingly he said that he would
like you because you know he's you it is
a kind of like competitive business and
it's one of these things where people
have their egos involved and stuff but
like I'm just I'm at a Juris like I
don't care about that kind of stuff
anymore I'm like yeah but let me go are
you so you're saying let me come on a
couple of dates and play in front of a
large crowd and have a good time
beautiful theatre yeah yeah yeah and the
cool thing is I mean people listen to
this conversation hopefully had a few
laughs get a little bit of insight but
but truly just like my comedy has been
for the last 15 years like come to the
show if you really want to know where
I'm at and and and if you really want to
have a like an amazing full night of
comedy then I guarantee it I know when
people come out because I did these
shows last year and people were
overwhelmingly saying please go out and
do like a full tilt toward oh that's
great yeah I'm ready to go man I mean
it's something that's great about like
that's the thing about this no matter
what you've done with movies with
television records you know specials all
of that aside there's nothing like being
in front of a live audience
and then also interacting with them
afterwards yeah and there's even even
better to that is like there's when
you're past the point where so much is
expected of you to stay at a certain
status that's impossible for anybody
Elvis or you know Tom Cruise everybody's
gotta take their licks and so to be at a
point in my life in career where I can
bring more to the table and to be able
to entertain people with greater options
it's that's the kind of show you want
that's the show I want to see I've you
know gone and seen Aerosmith I didn't
even know how many times in my life I
went through periods my life I didn't
like the music
there wasn't albums that I loved but I
stick with them and you watch them go
through this thing now you're seeing
them see the world from a whole
different perspective so I'm I'm that's
where we all right I'm gonna I'm not the
young bull and I'm so happy to be the
you know the old bull and to be able to
sit and have conversations with my with
my Bros like this man well I wish you
all the best and I'm sure it's gonna be
a fantastic tour and I and I know that
that's not even gonna be the end of it I
mean we hear your story has not written
been written yet that the ending has now
been written and your letter murdered
yeah we used to have a toilet to die out
like Elvis right that'll be like that's
how I want to go out but um but I want
to thank you for coming on I truly
appreciate it I know it was like you
know weird time of day to come out here
all the way to the all things comedy
studio but I look forward to having you
on again and seeing you out there and
like I said I wish you all the best and
I really appreciate you coming on your
sweetheart man thank you thank you for
having me on your show and continued
success on your
and I appreciate and by the way we
talked a lot about me but you're a funny
[ __ ] too oh I'm gonna have a
hole okay I'm gonna need to get look at
that you know what we got to do that
flip flip and I wear the glasses
thank you cannot in a stache kind of
work here we go everybody what's the
weirdest at least you didn't say the
same joke everybody says come off that's
like the I think I want to sell this for
Halloween I think I've already been sold
by Halloween yeah but that would my name
on it
[Laughter]
on the merch paid entrepreneur I'm still
learning from Dane Cook like see you
know I'm selling them out of my truck
people like what are you doing just come
inside I think I gotta do it this way
but anyways that's another fantastic
episode of rhythm with Griffin the Great
Dane Cook I appreciate him coming on and
you guys keep listening and keep sending
me comments keep sending in theme songs
guys cuz I don't know if you can top
today's theme song every every week it
seems to get popped you keep going
higher and higher so let's keep doing
that and thanks for listening and this
has been Eric Griffin and we're signing
off
[Music]